hey this is a pretty big deal uh former
attorney general eric holder
is now predicting that donald trump and
his top administration officials will be
indicted will be indicted uh newsweek
writes former attorney general eric
holder predicted friday that trump as
well as other top officials from the
former president's administration
will be invited by the uh indicted by
the u.s government over the events of
january 6 2021 and their efforts to
change the 2020 results in early may
holder told cbs news he believed trump's
actions related to january 6 merit an
indictment hundreds of trump supporters
attacked the u.s capitol that day after
the then president told them to walk to
the federal legislative building and
fight like hell to save their country
those directions came after trump
claimed for months that biden's victory
was fraudulent while pressuring
officials across the country to overturn
the win on friday in an interview on
hbo's real time with bill maher holder
reiterated his view that trump should
face indictment let's uh take a look at
this video
of eric holder explaining this here to
bill maher on his show friday
if you were still the attorney general
about trump and january 6. well i'll
tell you if you'd asked me that question
uh about a year or so ago i would have
said i would have been awfully concerned
about the divisive nature of bringing a
case against a former president but now
because of what we know what great
journalists have done the leaks that
have come from the january 6 committee
if you show me that donald trump was
involved in the efforts to in essence
foment a coup and you can show the
requisite intent
he has to be indicted
and what would that entail after you
indict him
after you indict him well he would then
you know you take him to trial just like
anybody else i i think you know you can
look at what merrick garland is going to
do
i think my primary my first
analysis would be what's going to happen
to him in georgia right you've got him
on tape saying you know find me thousand
seven hundred eighty-four that's really
as close to a layup it seems to me right
i've always said the same thing about
that one why don't they just go after
that one moment it's on tape you have
the smoking gun he's saying
i mean i remember when rod blagojevich
was on tape
basically it didn't work out too well
for him no i know but but it was it was
it was it was pretty blatant but it
wasn't as bad as find me 11 000 votes
yeah yeah no i think as i said i think
that's close to a layup the d.a down
there is going to be calling witnesses i
understand before a special grand jury
but the interesting thing there is that
that can also be a specification and a
federal charge that could be brought in
washington dc when you're charging him
with conspiracy to defraud and
conspiracy to obstruct what happened in
georgia can actually be part of a
federal case as well so i think you know
i was a federal prosecutor doing
political corruption cases when i first
came to the justice department for 12
years and you get a feel for these
things after a while
i get the feeling that i can see where
this one is going and a lot of high
level people in the trump administration
i suspect the president himself people
at the justice department are all going
to find themselves
on a little document that says the
united states versus fill in the blame
so there is the prediction and the hope
would be
that the department of justice will view
the upcoming january 6th hearings which
start later this week
as a way to say well now we see it all
in detail and while the main purpose of
the january 6 committee is not criminal
investigation if they uncover we've
talked about this before if they un
cover criminal activity they refer to
the justice department to look at it and
what eric holder is saying is how the
how could they come to any other
conclusion now
there are some who will say the hearings
are sort of uh embarrassing enough that
you don't need to indict that's like the
prototypical susan collins thing
republican senator susan collins love to
say well i was very disappointed that
they incited the riotous insurrection
but the hearings were embarrassing
enough to them and that's enough
punishment we don't need to make this a
political show trial i'm sure they would
never do it again they've learned their
lesson that's the susan collins approach
you'll probably hear that from some
in the coming weeks after we see what
the january 6 committee has which will
be fascinating to see we'll have these
clips on our instagram which you can
find at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is crush organics
these guys are awesome they support the
show they have an excellent collection
of premium grade organic cbd products
crush organics has your oils your
topical creams gummies they even have
these great experience gift boxes which
are great for sending to someone this is
the one i received really beautifully
packaged crush has a daytime cbd blend
in peppermint as well as a nighttime
blend lots of people report cbd being
helpful for sleep crush's cbd topical
cream can be used on joints and muscles
definitely try the gummies too those are
great some people prefer the gummies
over the oils crush organics care a lot
about quality so you can feel good about
getting your cbd from them they're
always dropping new products pay
attention to the site and crush organics
are fans of the david pakman show just
like you i hope so they're giving you a
massive discount 40 off all products go
to crushorganics.us
and use the code pacman to save 40
percent the link is down below